a partir del 20 de septiembre el
gobierno de bailén ofrecerá las vacunas
de facer y de modernas para los
estadounidenses vacunados hace más de 8
meses esto sí la administración de
alimentos y drogas de eeuu lo aprueba
primero según oficiales del gobierno de
bailén la dosis de refuerzo también es
necesaria para las personas que
recibieron la vacuna de johnson y
johnson el anuncio viene después de que
se publicaran tres estudios que
demuestran que la protección de las
vacunas contra el coi disminuye con el
tiempo y es menos eficaz contra la
variable delta sin embargo según el
balance que la directora del centro de
control y prevención de enfermedades de
eeuu la vacuna es efectiva para evitar
síntomas severos hospitalización y
muertes de muchos estadounidenses
hay que mencionar que la ocupación en
hospitales sobre todo en el sur de eeuu
llega a niveles récord y que el 98 8% de
los nuevos casos de kobin en eeuu
corresponden a la variable dental al
respecto expertos
han reaccionado oponiéndose a la tercera
dosis argumentando que sólo es necesaria
para las personas con sistemas
inmunológicos débiles y adultos mayores
la organización mundial de la salud
también es se opuso a la idea de darle
una tercera dosis a personas saludables
mientras que en muchos países
simplemente no tienen vacunas para
salvar la vida de sus ciudadanos